so we're continuing sort of our tour
through the absolutely outrageous things
that donald trump said during his
rally-like press briefings at his own
golf club over the weekend
and yes this is reality as far as we
know and one of the things he said
and that he's been saying more and more
is he's going to protect people
with pre-existing conditions now you
might hear that and say wait
i remember this debate from 10 years ago
obamacare protects people with
pre-existing conditions and you would be
right
one of the big accomplishments of
obamacare that is very popular with the
entire country
it's not just democrats that like the
pre-existing condition
provision is that obamacare made it the
law
that health insurance companies can't
reject you because you have a
pre-existing condition they can't reject
coverage of that pre-existing condition
this is so popular that now donald trump
is just claiming he's going to do it by
executive order
except of course it's already the law
check this out it's really beyond belief
so over the next two weeks i'll be
pursuing a major executive order
requiring
health insurance companies to cover all
pre-existing conditions
for all customers that's a big
i've always been very strongly in favor
we have to cover pre-existing conditions
so we will be pursuing a major
executive order requiring health
insurance companies to cover
all pre-existing conditions for all of
its customers
this has never been done before but it's
time the people of our country are
properly represented
and properly taken care of now you're
not mishearing that
trump is promising to do something that
is already the law
thanks to obamacare if you can believe
this
trump saying this was reported as
breaking news by some media outlets it
was breaking news 10 years ago when the
affordable care act was first signed
into law
meanwhile trump's own administration is
suing
to try to dismantle the affordable care
act which is what protects people with
pre-existing conditions
we've never seen anything like this
before we really haven't and
part of why is because of who's in the
white house part of why
is because of who supports this guy
we've never seen anything like this
before
trump is saying i will sign an executive
order to enforce the law
from 2010 which i've been trying to
repeal
since i became president of the united
states the provision
trump wants to make law with an
executive order
is pre-existing if you can imagine that
we've had it for a decade now i
actually do not think that this is trump
being stupid
uh this was a speech that was on paper
in front of him right trump didn't just
come up with this
out of thin air he doesn't write the
speeches obviously
this is a calculation that he can do the
same thing with pre-existing conditions
that he's been doing with veterans
choice
there i think it's been a dozen times or
so that donald trump has said when asked
about his accomplishments from his first
term he says veterans choice
now veterans choice is an obama
accomplishment from 2014 and trump has
taken credit for it a dozen maybe two
dozen times
similarly here coverage of pre-existing
conditions is very popular with
americans as it should be
and donald trump is going to try to take
credit for it to get himself
re-elected he's throwing everything at
the wall to see what sticks
and what might help him in november
plain and simple nothing more nothing
less
and we know he will try to take credit
for a coronavirus vaccine which is
likely to enter emergency use
sometime around the election no thanks
to donald trump
we know trump will try to take credit
for any treatment
including ones that were tested mostly
in other countries
if they end up being effective to deal
with coronavirus
and he might get away with it that's the
understanding
we can't realize trump will try to take
credit for this stuff and laugh and say
ah
nobody's gonna fall for that no 63
million people voted for him in 2016. 63
million people already fell for it
there are clearly millions of americans
who will believe
that trump cured coronavirus or found a
vaccine or protected pre-existing
conditions
because they believe anything he says
and that's
what the next three months have to be
all about
which is to overwhelm the vote to such a
degree
that none of these bamboozlings and lies
actually help donald trump to get
reelected or
they'll help him but they won't actually
get him over the hump
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much
i love my helix mattress well i was
really excited to hear that helix has
launched a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable
sofas and chairs with the same level of
quality
and comfort that i expect from these
guys and all form is one of our sponsors
today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's solidly built
it's huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room their
prices are very reasonable and when you
get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get
20 off your entire order when you get
there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video